ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA
OKAY HAND. BENNETT BERMAN.
BIGELOW BLOOM. BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRIAN BURKE CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHEN CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DALY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KILEY LACKEY
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA. WHEN
DONALD PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS
CORK CROOKS SILVA RAMOS RAY IS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
C. R. TO SMITH STONE T. ROWE
THERE IS V. APPROVED LAW VOEPEL
WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM
IS PRESENT. HEY QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN THE
GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER. WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM YES SIR. IN
THE NAME OF GOD. THE MOST
GRACIOUS. MOST MERCIFUL. ONLY
GOD. WE ARE AMAZED AT THE MANY
BLESSINGS. YOU HAVE GIVEN TO US
AS A PEOPLE.YOU LOVE US SO MUCH
DID WE ARE MOVED TO CALL
OURSELVES ONE NATION UNDER GOD.
WE KNOW HOWEVER THAT WE ARE
BLESSED. SO THAT WE CAN BE A
REFLECTION OF YOUR LOVE IN THIS
WORLD. YOU MADE US A MIGHTY
NATION. MAY WE ALWAYS BE GENTLE
ENOUGH. TO LIFT UP THE FALLEN
AND READY ALWAYS TO PROTECT
THOSE WHO ARE UNABLE TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES. YOU MADE US A
BOUNTIFUL NATION. MAY WE ALWAYS
SHARE THOSE BLESSINGS WITH THE
HUNGRY THE HOMELESS THOSE UNABLE
TO CARE FOR THEMSELVES I MEAN.
THANK YOU MY RESEARCH YES OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOLEY. AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER COOLEY.
CALLING DRUM IN THE PLEDGE. SAN. INDIVISIBLE WITH S. OR- THANK
YOU MAYBE SEE. RIGHT READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
ASSEMBLY GERMAN SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY JANUARY SIXTH TWENTY
TWENTY TO THE ASSEMBLY MINUTE
NINETY M. THE AUDIBLE KEVIN
MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEMPORE
YOU'LL BE SIMPLY PRESIDING CHIEF
CLERK SUPPORTER OF A DESK CLERK
BOWMAN READING ROLL CALL A
RADIUS MOVES AND MISTER FLORA
SECONDS. AT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATION SAN
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES
FROM THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. AN
ISRAELI AS YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
BRIAN JONES SAWYER HOLDEN FORK
SILVA. PETRIE-NORRIS AND GIPSON
TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY EIGHT
MEMBERS ARE GIVING A ONE DAY
NOTICE. TO REMOVE THE FOLLOWING
BILLS FROM THE INACTIVE FILE
ITEM EIGHT NINE AB NINE SEVEN
FIVE AT THE REQUEST OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS RIVAS. ITEM
EIGHT TWENTY ONE AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE AT THE REQUEST OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER A REAL. THE
CLERK WILL NOT. MEMBERS WE ARE
APPROACHING THE DEADLINE FOR TO
YOUR BILLS. TODAY IS THE LAST
DAY TO NOTICE INTENT TO REMOVE
THE BILL FROM THE INACTIVE FILE
FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDING A BILL
. BY THE JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTH
AMENDMENT DEADLINE. IT IS ALSO
THE LAST DAY TO NOTICE INTENT ON
THE FLOOR TO REMOVE THE BILL
FROM THE INACTIVE FILE TO BE
RETURNED TO THIRD READING. ON
JANUARY. THIRTY FIRST. AT THIS
TIME WE ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE. SECOND
READING COOPERATE. WITH SOME
REAL. FOURTEEN TEN FIFTY EIGHT
ONE OH TWO TO NINETY FIVE THREE
TWENTY ONE THREE FIFTY THREE
THREE NINETY NINE FOUR EIGHT
FOUR FIFTY TO FORTY FIVE FIVE
TWENTY TWO FIVE FIFTY EIGHT FIVE
EIGHTY ONE FIVE NINETY FIVE SIX
SEVENTY SIX. 627-407-4088
549-021-0001 TEN SIXTY SEVEN TEN
NINETY THREE ELEVEN TWENTY
ELEVEN THIRTY FOUR ELEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN TWELVE EIGHTEEN TWELVE
TWENTY SEVEN. 441-287-1307
1-340-113-5513 691-406-1416
1-440-514-6715 002-150-5640.
NINE SIX SIXTY SEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT SEVEN SIXTY NINETY NINETY
FIVE NINE SIXTEEN. 881-381-1390
FOUR FIFTEEN FORTY ONE THIRTY
WITH A MINISTER TWENTY EIGHT
WITH A MEMBERS TO EIGHTY EIGHT
WITH A MEMBERS THREE ELEVEN WITH
MEMBERS FOR LIVING WITH PARENTS
FIVE FIFTY TWO WITH A MINUTE SIX
FORTY SIX OF THE MEMBERS SIXTY
FIVE MINUTES. SIX SIXTY ONE OF
THE MINUTES NINE TWENTY THREE
WITH A MENSTON FOURTEEN WITH
MEMBERS ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE THE
MINUTES WILL SIX THE MINISTER
FORTY WITH A MEMBERS WILL FORTY
NINE WITH MEMBERS TO ALREADY
TWENTY EIGHT WITH A MINUTES
FOURTEEN HUNDRED WITH A MEMBER
OF SENATE BILL FORTY FOUR
EIGHTEEN WITH A MEMBERS
ANSWERABLE TO FORTY FIVE. THANK
YOU DAVID. ALL BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED READ. AND AMENDMENTS.
DEEMED A. GOVERNOR'S VETOES FILE
ITEM SEVENTY THROUGH ONE TWELVE
ITEM SHALL BE CONTINUED. NOTICE
OF INTENTION TO REMOVE REMOVED
FROM AN ACTIVE FILE ITEMS ONE
THIRTEEN AND ONE FOURTEEN ARE
NOTICES. RECONSIDERATION FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTEEN. XABI CONTINUE. MEMBERS WE ARE AT ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING. WE ARE ASSEMBLY
THIRD. THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTEEN FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS. CLERK WILL READ WITH
AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
TWENTY THREE WITH A MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE THIS WILL
BE NINETY MINUTES YEAH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AMENDMENTS ARETECHNICAL IN
NATURE AND HAD CO AUTHORS I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE TO SEND THIS OUT
TO- BE ADOPTED AND HOW TO PRINT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR LEVINE
MR FLOOR WHAT PURPOSE SIR. WE
OBJECT THESE MOMENTS AFTER ROLL
CALL VOTE. MISTER FLORA IS
REQUESTING A ROLL CALL VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS. CLARK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS WE DESIRE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. JORDY PRESIDENT VOTING
IS THE THRESHOLD ON THE IMMENSE. CLARK WELL. BECAUSE ROLL TIE
THAT EYES FORTY ONE DOES
THIRTEEN THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS OUT TO PRINT. I AM
BACK ON FILE PASS AND RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN. THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTEEN. AB FIVE
TWENTY FOUR CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND
OTHERS IMMACULATE IN THE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. MR
RODRIGUEZ YOU MAY OPEN. THANK A
MISPRINT MEMBERS AB FIVE TWENTY
FOUR REQUIRE EACH COLLEGE TO
COLLECT SPECIFIC INFORMATION
FROM CAMPUSES RECOGNIZED
FRATERNITIES OR SORORITIES THIS
WILL ALSO REQUIRE INSTITUTIONS
TO ANNUALLY PUBLICIZED
INFORMATION COLLECTED INCLUDING
THE NUMBER OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
INCIDENT ON THE SCHOOL WEBSITE.
AND DISTRIBUTED OUT INFORMATION
VIA CAMPUS EMAIL. THIS BILL
WOULD INCREASE TRANSPARENCY
WHICH IS A KEY PIECE TO KEEPING
OUR STUDENTS SAFE RESPECT OUR
STRUGGLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS RODRIGUEZ. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
. CLICK LIBERAL. DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
WELL BECAUSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SIXTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM ONE
NINETEEN. SAYS FILE ITEM. ONE
TWENTY. AB. SIX SIXTY TWO
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIXTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RDRIGUEZ
AN ACCOLADE IN THE MENTAL HEALTH
MR RODRIGUEZ YOU MAKE IT OPEN.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX SIX TWO WOULD DIRECT
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY TO ESTABLISH A WORKING
GROUP TO LOOK INTO THE
CHALLENGES RELATED TO EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICE TRANSPORT MENTAL
HEALTH PATIENTS. EXISTING LAW IS
SILENT ON MENTAL HEALTH HOLDS
AND TRANSPORTS CONDUCTED BY
AMBULANCE PERSONNEL. THIS BILL
WOULD BEGIN AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION ENSURE PROTECTION
FOR BOTH PARTIES AND EMERGENCY
PERSONNEL ARE RESPECTIVELY.
THANK YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM.
CARCLUB THE ROLE. WHAT IS THAT
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A
VOTE. CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY ONE NO ZERO
. THAT MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE
GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN. ON
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY ONE ON
SENATE THIRD WE'RE GOING TO PASS
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS ONE TWENTY
TWO. ONE TWENTY THREE AND ONE
TWENTY FOUR.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS
FOR THE PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS
WILL RETURN TO FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN OF FILE I'M TWENTY ONE
ON THE SECOND READING FILE. THIS
IS MISS IRWIN. FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AB FIVE ANYONE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS COOPERATE
WITH MEN ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
EIGHTY ONE WITHIN MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ONE MEASUREMENT
ON THE MAMMOTHS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THESE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY
THAT NOT REPORTING STATE
AGENCIES CAN TRANSLATE SPECIFIC
FEDERAL CYBERSECURITY GUIDELINES
TO APPROPRIATELY APPLIED TO
THEIR OWN AGENCY MIRRORING HOW
THE BILL AUTHORIZES THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY TO
TRANSLATE THE GUIDELINES FOR
REPORTING AGENCIES THERE'S OTHER
THERE ARE OTHER CLARIFYING AND
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ABOUT
. THANK YOU MR ONE WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE I. SEVENTY
MEMBERS ARE DOTTED. BILLS AT THE
PRINTER BACK ON FILE. AND FILE
ITEM TWNTY ONE. IS AB ONE
THOUSAND ONE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CORKERY WITH A MAN
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THOUSAND ONE
WITH THE MINUTES BY SOME
REMEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA MISTER
SEA ON THE MENACE THANK YOU
MEMBERS THEM IN THIS OUR
TECHNICAL ARTICLE AUTHORS AND-
CLARIFYING DEFINITION LANGUAGE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- THANK YOU MR SEAH. MISTER
FLORA FOR PURPOSE SIR. WE OPPOSE
THESE MOMENTS AFTER ROLL CALL
VOTE. MISTER FLORES REQUESTING A
ROLL CALL ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO VOTE.
MAJORITY PRESENT IN VOTING IS
THE THRESHOLD. CLARK WELL.
BECAUSE ROLL TIDE OF THE EYES
FORTY FIVE NEWS FOURTEEN THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT
THE PRINTER BACK ON FILE. AND IS
RAMOS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR MOTION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO
ALLOW THE FOLLOWING AUTHORS. TO
TAKE UP THEIR ITEMS ON SECOND
READING TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE FOR THE PURPOSE OF THIRD
READING. ITEM TO AB FIFTY EIGHT
SALAS ITEM THREE AB ONE OH TWO
HOLDEN. ITEM SIX AB THREE FIVE
THREE O'DONNELL. ITEM TEN EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN NGUYEN. ITEM
FOURTEEN AB FIVE NINETY FIVE
MEDINA. ITEM SEVENTEEN AB SEVEN
FOUR ZERO MCCARTY AND ITEM
TWENTY SIX AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN OR ONE. THANK YOU MISTRESS
MISTER FLOOR WE OPPOSE NATURAL
COCOA. MR FLOOR WITHHOLDING MS
REYES MOVES AND- MR WARD SECONDS
ON THE RULES SUSPENSION CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE MEMBERS THIS
IS. MS RAMOS IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE MR FLOOR I KNOW.
BIZRATE'S IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND MR FLORIDA NO VOTE ON
THIS PROCEDURAL MOTION. CLERK
WILL. CULTURAL. HIGHS FORTY
SEVEN THOSE FIFTEEN THE RULES
ARE SUSPENDED.
BEVERAGES
CLARIFYING ON THAT LAST
PROCEDURAL MOTION FILE ITEM TEN
IS AB.
FOUR EIGHTY FIVE FORTY
FIVE. MEMBERS THESE ARE THE MORE
ITEMS. THIS IS ITEM NUMBER TWO
FILE ITEM TWO ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTY EIGHT BY MISTER SALAS.
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
IMMACULATE THE PEOPLE HEALTH MR
SALIHU MAILBOX THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY EIGHT WHICH
WILL IMPROVE YOUTH SUICIDE AND
SELF HARM PREVENTION BY ENSURING
THAT BEST PRACTICES AND MODEL
POLICY FOR SUICIDE AWARENESS AND
PREVENTION IDENTIFIED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ARE BEING UTILIZED BY
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES ARE
THIS IMPLEMENTS FINDINGS FROM A
REPORT FROM THE STATE AUDITOR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR-
IPHONE. THANK REST SALAS SEEING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. OR CALL THE ROLL. ESERVER
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLITORAL TIED
ABOUT I. SIXTY SIX NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE. AB ONE OH TWO
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OUT TO HOLDING
FOR COREY ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH
TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
AND ACCOLADES OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES MR HOLDEN YOU MAY OPEN
. THE SPEAKER. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
OH TWO REPRESENTS THE CONTINUED
PROMISE. OF THE COLLEGE AND
CAREER ACCESS PATHWAYS ALSO
KNOWN AS C. CAP. THIS BILL
REMOVES THE SENSE THAT
ORIGINALLY PER PLACED ON THE C.
CAP PROGRAM ALLOWS COURTS
SCHOOLS TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM SO JUSTICE INVOLVED
YOUTH. CAN RECEIVE ITS BENEFITS
. WHEN I FIRST INTRODUCED THIS
BILL I WAS MOTIVATED BY GROWING
OPPORTUNITY GAP. FACED BY THE
CHILDREN FROM DISADVANTAGED
BACKGROUNDS. I BELIEVE THAT IF
THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TAKE COLLEGE LEVEL COURSES THEY
WOULD GAIN THE CONFIDENCE AND
KNOWLEDGE TO EXCEL AND HIGHER
EDUCATION. AFTER SIX YEARS WE
HAVE SEEN THAT EXACTLY. IS
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED. DILLON
ROMAN STUDENTS ARE MORE LIKELY
TO ENTER COLLEGE RESIST TO
COMPLETION AND GRADUATE. THE
POSITIVE EFFECTS OF DORM ROOM IN
COLLEGE DEGREE ATTAINMENT ARE
MORE PRONOUNCED FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND FOR THEIR MORE
AFFLUENT PEERS. IT ALSO CREATES
PUBLIC SAVINGS BY REDUCING THE
TIME IT TAKES TO EARN A COLLEGE
DEGREE. BY REMOVING THE SUNSET
PROVISIONS FROM THIS PROGRAM WE
GIVE SCHOOLS THE CERTAINTY THEY
NEED TO ESTABLISH A LONG TERM
COMMITMENT TO THE PROGRAM.
THANKS DURING THE PROGRAM TO
COURTS SCHOOLS WE INSURE THE
EXACT POPULATION OF STUDENTS
THIS PROGRAM WAS MEANT TO HELP.
HAE ACCESS TO IT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK MISS HOLDEN.
SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION OF IT ON
THE ADAM. CORPORAL. THAT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS BUT IS ADAMANT.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
I. SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIX. AB THREE FIFTY THREE
O'DONNELL. CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE FIFTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OLD ALMANAC LATER WELL
REVENUE AND MAKING APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE MISTER O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT AB THREE FIVE
THREE WHICH WILL ELIMINATE THE
CAP ON THE OIL TRUST FUND AND
HELP ENSURE THE CLEAN UP OF
ABANDONED OIL WELLS IN MY
DISTRICT AND BE ON. THE LONG
BEACH THAILAND'S ARE HOME TO THE
WILMINGTON OILFIELD ONE OF THE
LARGEST OIL AND NATURAL GAS
FIELDS. IN OUR NATION. BECAUSE
THESE OPERATIONS ARE LOCATED ON
STATE LANDS THE STATE RECEIVES A
SHARE OF THE NET PROFITS. FROM
THESE OPERATIONS AND WILL BE
PARTIALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
CLEANING UP THE SITE WHEN
OPERATION SEES. TO ENSURE THE
STATE HAS THE FUNDS NECESSARY TO
DECOMMISSION THE WELLS AND
MITIGATE POTENTIAL ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS A PORTION OF THE STATE'S
PROFITS ARE JUST POSITIVE IN THE
OIL TRUST FUND. HOWEVER THIS
FUND HAS A CAP OF THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THAT FALLS SHORT
OF THE NINE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS NEEDED. THIS BILL
ELIMINATES THAT CAP I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MYSTERON
. SEE NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. CARCLUB
THE ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS FILE ITEM TEN.
AB FOUR EIGHTY FIVE CLERK WILL
READ. SOME PEOPLE FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUINN AND I
COULDN'T HATE CRIMES THIS ONE
YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I'M
PRISON BILL AB FOUR EIGHT FIVE
WHICH WAS INTRODUCED LAST YEAR
THAT WOULD REQUIRE LOOK LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
REPORT INCIDENTS AND SISTER SIX
RELATED HATE CRIMES ON THEIR OWN
WEBSITE MONTHLY. AS A REFUGEE
MYSELF WHO CAME HERE AS A YOUNG
CHILD I TO HAVE BEEN THE VICTIM
OF HATE OVER THE YEARS I HAVE
FIRST HAND KNOWLEDGE OF HOW
DEVASTATING HER FOR THESE CRIMES
CAN BE. NOBODY SHOULD BE MADE TO
FEEL THIS WAY AND WE SHOULDN'T
BUT WE MUST DO BETTER THE MORE
AT PREVENTING THESE CRIMES. AS
MENTIONED NUMEROUS TIMES LAST
YEAR HATE CRIMES HAVE RISEN.
SIGNIFICAN THE PAST TWO YEARS.
THAT'S OVER THIRTY HUNDRED DOC
MAKE CASES AGAINST ASIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY A LOAN IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. IN THE
MAJORITY OF VICTIMS HAVE BEEN
ASIAN AMERICAN WOMAN. THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
HARASSED THEY HAVE BEEN SON. FOR
PERSONAL PROPERTY HAS BEEN
VANDALIZED AND ENDS IN SOME
CASES. ACTS OF PHYSICAL VIOLENCE
AND DEATH HAVE OCCURRED. I
WORKED TIRELESSLY I'M MOVING
THIS LEGISLATION WORK AND LOOK
FORWARD TO MY- THE FLOOR TO MY
COLLEAGUES SHARE MY SAME VISION
FOR ADDRESSING HATE CRIMES IN
OUR STATE BY SUPPORTING THIS
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
RIGHT NOW LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY ONLY REQUIRED TO REPORT
HATE CRIME DATA TO THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE ANNUALLY.
EVEN RESIDENTS UNABLE TO OBTAIN
CRIMES IN THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES.
THE DEPARTMENT HISTORICALLY IS
ANYWHERE FROM SIX TO EIGHTEEN
MONTHS BEHIND I'M REPORTING TO
THE PUBLIC. ALL RESIDENTS HAVE A
RIGHT TO CURRENT CURRENT
INFORMATION RELATED HATE CRIMES
IN THE ERRORS IN ORDER TO FEEL
SAFE AND ALSO IT WOULD HELP
PUBLIC SAFETY IN THE PLEASED TO
MARK PARCHMENT. TO IMMEDIATELY
ACT UPON THESE CASES. I NEED
HELP WE NEED TO FEEL SAFE WITH
OUR COMMUNITY. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
REST ONE THIS SEEING NO
DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. OUR GLOBAL ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SIXTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
NINETY FIVE BY MR MEDINA CORKERY
. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE NINETY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AND
OTHER SNACK LETTING THE PUBLIC
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION DECLARE
OF YOURS HERE OFF THE BACK
IMMEDIATELY. MISTER MEDIA THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT AB FIVE NINETY
FIVE AB FIVE NINETY FIVE WILL
ENSURE THE DECISIONS ABOUT
ADMISSIONS- PROPOSALS BY THE CSU
ARE MORE TRANSPARENT HAVE PROPER
OVERSIGHT AND IMPACT ASSESSMENTS
AND COORDINATE IMPLEMENTATION
PLANS WITH THE PUBLIC ELEMENTARY
AND SECONDARY EDUCATION SYSTEMS.
C. ISSUES CURRENTLY CONSIDERING
AND ADDITION OF A NEW ADMISSION
POLICY THE PROPOSAL WOULD ADD
ONE YEAR OF QUANTITATIVE
REASONING COURSE WORK TO THE A.
G. SUBJECT ADMISSION
REQUIREMENTS RAISING THE
REQUIREMENTS FROM FIFTEEN YEARS
OF COMPREHENSIVE COLLEGE PREP
WORK TO SIXTEEN YEARS FOR THE
ENTERING FRESHMAN CLASS. OF
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN. THE
ADDITIONAL YEAR OF QUANTITATIVE
REASONING AS AN ADMISSIONS
REQUIREMENT COULD EXACERBATE THE
VERY SAME STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS THAT THE STATE IS WORKING
HARD TO OVERCOME. AB FIVE NINETY
FIVE IS SUPPORTED BY ADDRESS AND
OTHER EDUCATIONAL EQUITY GROUPS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR MEDINA.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CARCLUB THE ROLE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF OUR DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK
WELL. CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO ON
THE MEASURE THAT BILL PASSES.
WE'RE IT. WE'RE FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN. AB SEVEN FORTY
BROKERAGE. SOME PEOPLE SEVEN
FORTY BY ASSEMBLY MCCARTY AND
OTHERS NECKLACE IN A FOSTER
YOUTH MR MCCARTY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THIS MEASURE AB
SEVEN FORTIES A BILL TO PROTECT
THE RIGHTS OF OUR STUDENTS IN
THE FOSTER YOUTH SYSTEM I WE
KNOW THE FOSTER YOUTH FACE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES IN THEIR
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I SUSPENDED AT A RATE
FOUR TIMES GREATER THAN THAN THE
STATEWIDE AVERAGE. THISBILL
WOULD SIMPLY REQUIRE THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS NOTIFY THE FOSTER
CHILD COURT APPOINTED ATTORNEY
AND A SOCIAL WORKER IF THE
STUDENT IS PROPOSED TO BE
EXPELLED THROUGH THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM GIVING THEM MORE I
REPRESENTATION OPTIONS TO FOCUS
ON THEIR OUTCOMES THE STUDENT.
THIS BILL HAS YET NO OPPOSITION
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ASKEY RIVAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
KERN. SENIOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. ON THE ITEM CLICK CLUB
MORAL. ESERVER ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE RESERVE VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE IN KELLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES AND FINALLY THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWENTY SIX. AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN BY MR WIN CLERK
WILL READ SOME GIRL LIVING
EIGHTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
IRWIN AND ACCOLADES COMMUNITY
COLLEGES MEASURE WHEN YOU MAIL.
THANK YOU- MISTER SPEAKER AB
ELEVEN EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN WILL
INCREASE ACCESS TO SUPERVISE
TUTORING AT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BY ALLOWING
COLLEGES TO CLAIM A PORTION OF
FUNDING FOR A GREATER NUMBER OF
COURSES. THIS FUNDING IS
CRITICAL FOR CAMPUSES TO ASSIST
STUDENTS WITH EXPERIENCE
LEARNING LOSS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
NEED ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT.
THANK YOU MR ONE. C. NOTICE
KASHER DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CARCLUB THE ROLE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO
GO. CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLE CHINA
I. SIXTY SIX NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
GERMAN TO MEMORY. MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS. OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
WE ARE AT A GERMAN TO MEMORY THE
QUORUM CALL IS STILL IN PLACE
MEMBERS THE QUORUM CALL. IS
STILL IN PLACE AT THIS TIME
PLEASE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS.
OFF OF THE FLOOR. OR PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS WHERE A GERMAN TO
MEMORY. THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
WERE GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION.
TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MISTER BRIAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS ARRIVED ON OF THE LIFE
AND WORK OF A FORMER MEMBER OF
THIS BODY. FORMER CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS A TITAN IN THE FIFTY
FOURTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. THE
HONORABLE WILLARD MERRY JUNIOR.
FOR MARIE PUBLIC SERVICE WAS NOT
JUST A JOB. WAS IN AFRICA AN
AFFIRMATIVE DUTY HE SPENT NEARLY
HIS ENTIRE ADULT LIFE IN PUBLIC
SERVICE FIGHTING FOR JUSTICE.
FUNDING TO IMPROVE EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR
COMMUNITY FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIA
. HE WAS BORN JANUARY FOURTH
FIRST NINETEEN THIRTY ONE. WILL
IT SENIOR AND VIVIAN MARIE FROM
AN EARLY AGE HE SAW THE POWER OF
EDUCATION TO EXPAND OPPORTUNITY
FOR ALL. AFTER GRADUATING FROM
JEFFERSON HIGH SCHOOL HE STUDIED
AT EAST LA COLLEGE. UCLA AND
GRADUATED WITH A BACHELOR'S OF
SCIENCE FROM CAL STATE
NORTHRIDGE. YOU'RE A LAW DEGREE
FROM LOYOLA LAW SCHOOL AND AN
MBA. MELHAM YOU. HE UNDERSTOOD
THAT EDUCATION WAS THE GREAT
EQUALIZER. WHICH IS WHY IF THAT
WAS THE CENTER FOR AFRICAN
AMERICAN EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE
AND ACHIEVEMENT AT CAL STATE
DOMINGUEZ HILLS. MARIE ALSO
SERVED HIS COUNTRY. OUR COUNTRY
IN THE U. S. AIR FORCE. NINETEEN
FIFTY ONE TO NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT. BEFORE THE KOREAN WAR. HE
BEGAN HIS WORKING LIFE IN THE
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY A VIBRANT
PART OF THE SALAKO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY. WHAT IS
MISSION OF SERVICE AN ADVOCACY
TOOK HIM INTO THE REALM OF
POLITICS. AND ACTIVISM. HIS
ENTREE INTO POLITICS. CAME WHEN
HE STARTED WORKING FOR LOS
ANGELES MAYOR SAM YORTY.
COUNCILMEMBERS ROBERT FERRELL
BILLY MILLS HE WAS A KEY ADVISER
AND DEPUTY TO FORMER LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR AND CONGRESS MEMBER
MYRMIDON. THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER
PARTICULARLY AS A DISTINGUISHED
EXECUTIVE RESPECTIVELY HE SHARED
HIS MENTORSHIP AND SUPPORT WITH
COUNTLESS YOUNG PEOPLE. HE WAS
ELECTED TO THIS BODY IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT. TO REPRESENT THE
PEOPLE OF THE FOR THE FOR THE
FAMILY DISH MIGHT IMPACT
CONTINUES TO BE FELT. THROUGH
HIS WORK A CHECK AS CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE ON
STATE ADMINISTRATION. AS WELL
AS- A FORMIDABLE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS. IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMPION LEGISLATION THAT
REQUIRED THE STATE TO PROVIDE
LITERACY PROGRAMS FOR ADULTS AND
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED. AS A PERSON HE
LOVES JAZZ. IF THAT WAS THE
INSTITUTE ON PRESERVATION OF
JAZZ AS AN ART FORM AT CATHOLIC
UNIVERSITY. LONG BEACH. MURRAY
WAS MARRIED TO HIS WIFE BARBARA
. FROM NINETEEN FIFTY SIX UNTIL
HER PASSING IN NINETEEN NINETY
ONE. HE AND HIS SON A NAME WE
MIGHT REMEMBER ON THIS BODY AS
WELL. FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FORMER SENATOR KEVIN MURRAY THEY
WERE THE FIRST FATHER SON PAIR
TO SERVE THE STATE ASSEMBLY AT
THE SAME TIME. WE WOULD MARIE
PASSED AWAY ON DECEMBER
TWENTIETH. DAYS BEFORE HIS
NINETY FIRST BIRTHDAY. MAY HE
REST IN POWER. MAYES LEGACY OF
UPLIFTING EDUCATION AND
UPLIFTING ALL PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. STAY TRUE IN THIS
BODY IN HIS ABSENCE. INTO A FAN
WHO COULDN'T MAKE IT HERE TODAY
BUT I WATCHING IT. NO THAT THE
LEGACY OF WILL WILL IT MARINO
DISTRICT IT'S FELT ALL THE
COMMUNITY. AND I CARRY IT WITH
ME ON MY SHOULDERS NOW
REPRESENTING HIS PLACE IN THE
CITY. MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME AND
ADJOURNING SESSION TODAY IN
HONOR. AMANDA FAMILY AMANDA
SERVICE SACRIFICE. OPPORTUNITY
JUSTICE. WILL IT MARIE SINGH GEN
. THANK YOU MISTER PRIME AND
MISTER JONES ARE YOU TWO ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE SHERMAN MEMORY
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
TO WANT TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES AND AN HONORING
OF NOT ONLY A GREAT MAN BUT A-
FAMILY FRIEND WILLARD BARRY.
TRUE LEGEND HAVE LONG WALK THE
HALLS OF THIS CAPITAL. AND WILL
A VERY WAS NO EXCEPTION. WILL IT
WAS ONE OF A KIND. HE WAS
THOUGHTFUL INTENTIONAL. AND
GENEROUS AND BOTH HIS KINDNESS
AND HIS COACHING. YOU WILL NOT
YOU WILL NOT HAVE TO BE LOOK
VERY FAR TO FIND SOMEONE WHO HAS
BEEN IMPACTED BY HIS GREATNESS.
WILL WAS ALWAYS EAGER TO SHARE
HIS VAST LIFE EXPERIENCE AND
WIDELY KNOWN FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO NURTURE US YOUNG. BACK THEN I
WAS YOUNG. BLACK IT PUBLIC
COMING PROFESSIONALS. HE WAS NOT
SHY ABOUT LETTING YOU KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT YOU ARE TO THOSE WHO
CAME BEFORE YOU. AND THOSE WHO
ARE COMING AFTER YOU. IF I HAD A
DOLLAR. THE TIME WHETHER MURRAY
PULLED ME TO THE SIDE AND SAID
LOOK YOUNG BLOOD LET ME TELL YOU
HOW TO DO IT RIGHT. I'D BE A
VERY WEALTHY MAN RIGHT NOW. WILL
ALWAYS HAD A WAY OF BRINGING
THIS BRING THE BEST. OUT OF
PEOPLE HE ALWAYS FOUND THE TIME
TO PUSH PEOPLE TO REACH THEIR
FULLEST POTENTIAL AND TO DO THE
VERY BEST IN ALL THINGS. FOR
THOSE OF US. IN THIS ROOM WHO'S
EVER BEEN TO A CHAOTIC. DO FRONT
TIER DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ENDORSEMENT. OR DISCUSSION ABOUT
A CONTROVERSIAL BILL. OR IDEA
AND HOW CRAZY IT IS IN THAT ROOM
. WAS ALWAYS WILLARD BERRY B.
CITY TO THE SIDE. IT RAISES HAIR
THE VOICE OF REASON WOULD COME
ACROSS THE ROOM. AND WE WOULD TO
BASE UP THERE FOR AN HOUR. AND
WITHIN TWO MINUTES WITH THE
RESULT. THAT'S HOW BRILLIANT A
MAN HE WAS AND THAT'S WHAT HE'S
GONNA BE SORELY MISSED BECAUSE
HE BROUGHT. HE BROUGHT LOGIC TO
CHAOS. THIS IS ONE OF THE MANY
LESSONS I PICKED UP FROM
WILLARD. TODAY I CAN SAY I'M A
BETTER MAN. FOR HAVING KNOWN HIM
I THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT HE
TAUGHT ME. WILL IT WILL SURELY
BE MISSED I AM THANKS FOR THE
TIME THAT I HAD WITH THEM. THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES FOR JOINING ME
WITH ME TODAY. SESSION TO HONOR
DILUTES THE LEGACY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHEELER H. MURRAY JUNIOR
. THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
MISTER GIBSON YOU TWO ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR SPEAKING MEMBERS LET ME ADD
MY VOICE TO THE CHORUS OF THOSE
WHO'VE SPOKEN ONE OF THANK THE-
DISTINGUISHED GENTLEMAN FROM
CULVER CITY. OF A BRING IN THIS-
COMMEMORATION OF FOR US INTO MY
COLLEAGUE. OF REPRESENTING LOS
ANGELES- MISTER BYRON SO ENJOY
YOUR SAWYER- LET ME SIMPLY SAY
WITHOUT BEING REDUNDANT-
EVERYTHING THAT MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE SAID- WILL IT MERRY WILL
TRULY BE MISSED- TO HAVE A
DISTINGUISHED. CAREER IN THIS
BODY FOR SO MANY YEARS- THE MAN
THE MYTH THE LEGEND. OF WILL IT
MERRY I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS A
YOUNG TADPOLE. OUT WORKING FOR
SEIU LOCAL NINETY NINE IN HAVE
TO LOBBY HIM ON A PARTICULAR
BILL THE NINETY ONE FREEWAY WAS
EXTREMELY CROWDED- WHICH MADE ME
LATE TO THAT MEETING. AND WILL
HAVE TO MAKE A DECISION WHETHER
NOT HE WANTED TO HEAR FROM ME
BECAUSE I INTERRUPTED HIM IN THE
MIDDLE OF HIS LUNCH. I REMEMBER
WITH CHEESE AND PEARS EVENT OF
ANY HAD- HIS NAPKIN TIED IN HIS.
THROAT TO MAKE SURE YOU GET
ANYTHING ON HIM AND HE WAS VERY
MATTER OF FACT HE DIDN'T HIDE
HIS FEELINGS- AND I WAS AFRAID-
MELINDA I WAS AFRAID OF YOUR
FATHER- DURING THAT PARTICULAR
MOMENT IN TIME BUT I SHOULD
NEVER FORGET. BECAUSE BEING ON
TIME IS LATE- AND ALSO YOU NEED
TO RESPECT PEOPLE'S TIME AND I
RESPECT WILL AMERICA- FROM THAT
TIME ON- I BEGIN TO GROUP TO
GROW CLOSE IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES FOR THOSE WHO. LIVE
THERE HEARD ABOUTPOLITICS IN
LAW SANDERS WILMER WAS BEHIND
ALL THE POLITICS HE WAS BEHIND
THE STRATEGIES MY COLLEAGUE
INDICATED THAT HE WORKED FOR THE
END OF FORMER LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR MERVYN TIMELY DID HE
WORKS FOR- UNITED STATES
CONGRESSMAN MERVYN DIAMOND. AND
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON- HE WAS
A POLITICAL GENIUS. WHEN IT HOW
TO START HE ALSO PUT OUT AS
SLATE OF A NEWSPAPER THAT OPTION
THERE FORGET THAT I BOUGHT IN
TWO YEARS YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS
RUNNING FOR OFFICE ON THE- TO
THE CITY COUNCIL HE HAD POWER
AND HE HAD WAIT. AND SO LET ME
SIMPLY SAY TO HIS CHILDREN.
EARNING MELINDA MURDERING. ARE
YOU FATHER. TOO RECAP. THANK YOU
FOR SHE YOUR FATHER WITH MANY OF
US. HE LEGACY IS WORKING THE
WATER REPLENISHED BOARD A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE
METROPOLITAN BOARD FOR ALMOST
TEN YEARS- NO ONE COULD EVER
REPLACE THIS GREAT- DRUM MAJOR
NOT ONLY FOR CIVIL RIGHTS. TO
HUMAN RIGHTS TO EDUCATE. AND THE
LIST JUST GOES ON AND ON SO FOR
ME I'M JUST HAPPY THAT HE PASSED
MY WAY MEMBERS. JUST REFERENCE
THIS GREAT MAN WHO WALKED ON
THIS FLOOR AND WE APPRECIATE THE
FAMILY FOR SURE WITH HIM WITH
HIM FOR SO MANY YEARS WITH ALL
OF US THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS
GIBSON THANK YOU MEMBERS WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY WE WILL LIFT THE QUORUM
CALL AT THIS TIME. WE ASK THAT
YOU. TAKE YOUR SEATS FOR YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
WE HAVE ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WILL
BE A TURNING IN THE MEMORY AT
THIS TIME. MR HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
. I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF THE LATE APARTHEID
OPPONENT NOBEL PEACE PRIZE
RECIPIENT AND ARCHBISHOP DESMOND
TUTU. FOR HIS LIFETIME
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS POLITICAL AND RELIGIOUS
LEADERS. TWO TWO WAS BORN ON
OCTOBER OF NINETEEN THIRTY ONE
AND WHAT AND WHAT IS NOW THE
NORTH WEST PROVINCE OF SOUTH
AFRICA. TWO TWO DRIVEN BY HIS
URGE TO SERVE HIS COMMUNITY
MOVED UP THE LADDER WITHIN THE
COUNCIL OF CHURCHES. EVENTUALLY
BECOMING THE FIRST BLACK GENERAL
SECRETARY OF THE COUNCIL. WHEN
LEADERS OF THE APARTHEID
MOVEMENT WERE JAILED OR EXILED
FOR SPEAKING OUT AGAINST THE
GOVERNMENT. TO STEPPED UP AS A
LEADER. AND THE SOUTH AFRICAN
COUNCIL OF CHURCHES ACTED AS A
MAJOR NON VIOLENT FORCE IN THE
MOVEMENT AGAINST APARTHEID. THE
BUSH OF USES PULPIT AND
COMPELLING OR TITIAN'S TO
CONDEMN THE HORRORS APARTHEID.
DISSUADE PEOPLE FROM ENGAGING IN
VIOLENT PROTESTS AND URGED
INTERNATIONAL SUPPORT. OF ANTI
APARTHEID MOVEMENT. TWO TWO ONE
A NOBEL PEACE PRIZE FOR HIS
NONVIOLENT EFFORTS MOBILIZING
AGAINST APARTHEID AND SOON AFTER
HE BECAME THE FIRST BLACK AND
SILICON BISHOP OF JOHANNESBURG.
WE CELEBRATE HIM IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF HOW THE ANTI
APARTHEID MOVEMENT. TO WHAT
OTHER ACTIVISTS MOTIVATED OUR
STUDENTS AND LEGISLATORS TO ACT
. THE STUDENTS OF UC BERKELEY
LED THE WAY PUSHING THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DIVEST IN
SOUTH AFRICA AND FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAXINE WATERS
INTRODUCED A BILL TO DO THE SAME
. THESE EFFORTS LED TO GIVE A
PASSIONATE APPEAL ON THIS FLOOR
TO A JOINT SESSION OF THE
LEGISLATURE. CALIFORNIA AND THE
UC'S EVENTUALLY DIVESTED.
APARTHEID ENDED AND THE REST AS
THEY SAY IS HISTORY. DESMOND
TUTU IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF
OVER SIXTY YEARS AND THEIR FOUR
CHILDREN AND SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNMENT HAS BEEN. I THANK
YOU MR HOLDEN. AND MISS
PETRIE-NORRIS ON THIS GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I TO RISE TO HONOR A TRULY
INCREDIBLE LEADER MAN AND
INSPIRATION I ARCHBISHOP DESMOND
TUTU I HAD I HAD THE PRIVILEGE
OF SPENDING THREE YEARS IN SOUTH
AFRICA IN MY MID TWENTIES I
ARRIVED IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE
FIVE YEARS AFTER THE END OF
APARTHEID AND THE HARD FOUGHT
CREATION AS A DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNMENT. IN THIS BEAUTIFUL
RAINBOW NATION THE TERM FIRST
COINED BY THE ARCHBISHOP TO
DESCRIBE POST APARTHEID SOUTH
AFRICA. AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
PASADENA NOTED ARCHBISHOPS AT
TUTU'S ROLE IN ENDING THE BRUTAL
REGIME OF APARTHEID REALLY
CANNOT BE OVERSTATED. SEVENTY
TWO DREW NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL ATTENTION TO THE
INEQUITIES OF APARTHEID HE
EMPHASIZED NONVIOLENT PROTEST
AND HE ENCOURAGED THE
APPLICATION AND ECONOMIC
PRESSURE ON SOUTH AFRICA. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR HE WAS
RECOGNIZED FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
WITH THE NOBEL PEACE PRIZE. AND
INCREDIBLY THOUGH THE
ARCHBISHOP. EW THE INDIGNITIES
OF APARTHEID HE EXPERIENCED THE
INJUSTICE OF THIS BRUTAL SYSTEM
HE NEVER ALLOWED HIMSELF TO GROW
BETTER HE NEVER ALLOWED HIMSELF
TO HATE HIS OPPRESSORS. HE
CHAIRED THE NATION'S TRUTH AND
RECONCILIATION COMMISSION WHICH
DOCUMENTED THE VICIOUSNESS OF
APARTHEID BUT IT ALSO GAVE THE
NATION A PATH TO MOVE FORWARD
TOGETHER IN PEACE. AND
ACCOMPLISHED WHAT SEEMED ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE THE PEACEFUL
TRANSITION OF POWER FOR THE NEW
SOUTH AFRICA. WITH HIS PASSING
SOUTH AFRICA AND THE ENTIRE
WORLD REALLY HAS LOST A GIANT
INCLUDING I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
LEAVE YOU WITH HIS WORDS. WHEN
WE SEE OTHERS AS THE ENEMY WE
RISK BECOMING WHAT WE HATE WHEN
WE OPPRESS OTHERS WE END UP
OPPRESSING OURSELVES. ALL OF OUR
HUMANITY IS DEPENDENT UPON
RECOGNIZING THE HUMANITY IN
OTHERS. MAY HIS LIFE AND HIS
LEGACY CONTINUE TO BE AN
INSPIRATION TO DATE AND FOR MANY
GENERATIONS. THANK RESERVATION
OUR SCHOOL MR HOLDEN YOU OR GET
REPRESENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. THE LARA SECOND BOTTOM
WITH A FRIEND AND DEVOTED CIVIL
RIGHTS PIONEER WHO PAVED THE WAY
FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS OVER
FIFTY YEARS AND MY COMMUNITY.
THE LAWRENCE WAS BORN IN NEW
ORLEANS IN NINETEEN THIRTY ONE.
AND MOVED TO THE CITY OF
ALTADENA AND NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR
AFTER SERVING IN THE WOMEN'S
AUXILIARY CORPS. IN WORLD WAR
TWO. SHE BEGAN HER WORK
ADVOCATING FOR HER CHILDREN AND
LOCAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS ALONGSIDE
HER HUSBAND. LBJ HECKINGBOTTOM.
BY PUSHING FOR IMMIGRATION AND
THE PASSING A UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. THEY GATHER THEIR
EFFORTS HELP MAKE THE P. UST THE
FIRST DISTRICT WEST OF THE
MISSISSIPPI THE EMPLOYMENT
BUSING FOLLOWING A LANDMARK U.
S. SUPREME COURT CASE. THE
LAWRENCE WAS A FOUNDING MEMBER
OF THE PASSING EDUCATION
FOUNDATION AND SHE WORKED
CLOSELY WITH BLACK LEADERS IN
PASADENA ONISSUES INCLUDING
CIVIL RIGHTS AND WOMEN'S RIGHTS
FAMILY SUPPORT. AND EDUCATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS. HE PLAYED AN
INSTRUMENTAL ROLE IN THE
ELECTION OF LORETTA THOMPSON
GLICKMAN AS THE FIRST BLACK
WOMAN ELECTED AS THE PASADENA
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER VICE MAYOR
AND SUBSEQUENTLY MAYOR. HE
SERVED ON THE STAFF OF SENATORS
WATER STERN. RICHARD POLANCO AND
JACK SCOTT AND WAS HONORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE AND
THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN AS AN
UNSUNG HERO OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT. DOORS WILL BE
REMEMBERED AS A BEACON OF HOPE
FOR ALL THOSE WHO HAVE COMMITTED
THEMSELVES TO IMPROVING THE
QUALITY OF LIFE. FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS. HE WAS AN AMAZING
HUMAN BEING. I'M A LIFELONG
ADVOCATE OF SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
EQUITABLE EDUCATION. FOR LOSS IS
FELT NOT ONLY BY HER COMMUNITY
ABOUT THE DATA AND PASADENA BUT
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES LEADERS
IN EDUCATION. AND PUBLIC SAFETY
AS WELL AS OUR FRIENDS AND
FAMILY. IS PRECEDED IN DEATH BY
HER HUSBAND AND HER MEMORY WILL
BE CHERISHED BY THEIR FOUR
CHILDREN AND GRANDDAUGHTER.
THANK YOU MR HOLDEN AND YOU ARE
GETTING RECOGNIZED FOR AN
ADDITIONAL A GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. ALL
RIGHTS TO REQUEST WILL JOIN IN
THE MEMORY OF AN ELK GROVE
RESIDENT JOHN COAXING. MY
PREVIOUS CHIEF OF STAFF ROBIN
CLARKSON'S FATHER IN LAW. JOHN
WAS BORN IN CHARLESTON SOUTH
CAROLINA AS THE SECOND OLDEST OF
ELEVEN CHILDREN. HE SERVED IN
THE UNITED STATES AIR FORCE AND
SERVED TOURS IN KOREA AND
VIETNAM UNTIL HE WAS EXPOSED TO
AGENT ORANGE AND LEFT A 100%
DISABLED. HERE'S A PURPLE HEART
BRONZE STAR VETERAN WHEN HE
RETIRED AFTER TWENTY THREE YEARS
IN THE AIR FORCE AT THE RANK OF
TECHNICAL SERGEANT. JOHN WENT ON
TO WORK FOR THE UNITED STATES
POSTAL SERVICE. UNITED STATES
DEFENSE DEPARTMENT AND FINALLY
AS A DIPLOMAT THE SAUDI ARABIAN
GOVERNMENT. JOHN MET HIS WIFE
JUNE BETTY. WHILE STATIONED IN
ENGLAND AND THEY HAVE SIX
CHILDREN TOGETHER. THE COUPLE
TRAVELED EXTENSIVELY THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD VISITING DESTINATIONS
SUCH AS KENYA THAILAND AND
GERMANY. NOT ALWAYS STRIVE TO BE
AN EXEMPLARY ROLE MODEL AND
PROVIDER FOR HIS FAMILY DESPITE
HIS DIFFICULT UPBRINGING IN THE
JIM CROW SOUTH. YOU NEVER MATTER
YOU NEVER LET THE HONORS OF
RECORDS OF RACISM. WELL HIS
PERSONAL SUCCESS. AND EVEN
WORKED THREE JOBS WHILE
ATTENDING NIGHT SCHOOL TO EARN A
COLLEGE DIPLOMA THAT OPEN
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HIM AND HIS
FAMILY. JOHN WAS A COP CONSERVE
SEWERS OF INSPIRATION TO THOSE
AROUND HIM AND HIS MEMORY IS
CHERISHED BY HIS SIX CHILDREN.
THIRTEEN GRANDCHILDREN AND
ELEVEN GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. IS
REMEMBERED AS A DEDICATED AND
FAITHFUL FATHER HUSBAND AND
FRIEND AND I RESPECTFULLY ASKED
WE ADJOURNED AND HIS. THANK YOU
MISS HOLDEN. N. MS CLARK SILVA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF MR MICHAEL CLEMENTS
WHO PASSED AWAY IN FULLERTON
CALIFORNIA ON JANUARY SECOND TE
CHAMPION OF SOCIAL JUSTICE
ISSUES FOR DECADES DECADES MIKE
FOUGHT TO CREATE A BETTER WORLD
FOR FARMWORKERS WORKING CLASS
LATINOS UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
THE HOMELESS. AND AT RISK YOUTH
AND STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
ONE CAMPAIGN AT A TIME MY
CONSIDERED BECOMING A MAN OF
CLOTH IN HIS YOUTH BUT
ULTIMATELY DECIDED TO CEASE READ
THE GOSPEL OF SOCIAL JUSTICE
INSTEAD. FIVE DECADES AGO MIGHT
CUT HIS TEETH WITH THE BEST AND
VOLUNTEERED WITH UNITED FIVE
MORE FARM WORKERS OF AMERICA
WHEN CESAR CHAVEZ LED THE UNION
. IN THE LATE NINETEEN SIXTIES
MIKE CONTINUED ORGANIZING AND
WORKING IN THE FIELDS OF WEALTH
SERENE AS A SEMINARIAN AT A
FRESNO PARISH. IN THAT TIME HE
MET MEDINA HIS FOR FUTURE WIFE
OF ALMOST FIFTY YEARS THEY WED
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO HE SOON
RETURNED TO HIS NATIVE ORANGE
COUNTY AND SERVED AS AN EARLY
DIRECTOR OF THE GEHRY CENTER IN
LA HABRA. I JURADO ABUSE
COUNSELING SERVICE WELL LIVING
IN SANTA ANA MIKE HELPED FOUND
THE SANTA ANA NEIGHBORHOOD
ORGANIZATION IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX A FAITH BASED COLLABORATIVE
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATED FOR
BETTER SERVICES AND WORKING
CLASS BARRIOS LIKE SANTA ANA.
SUN EVENTUALLY EXPANDED ITS
SERVICES AND REBRANDED AS THE
OQO AND CONTINUES ITS FAITH
BASED ACTIVISM TODAY. DURING THE
NINETEEN NINETIES IKE WORKED
AGAINST PROPOSITION ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN THE DEVICE IS A DIVISIVE
BALLOT INITIATIVE THAT AIM TO
DENY UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
FROM ACCESSING PUBLIC HEALTH
CARE SOCIAL SERVICES. AND
EDUCATION HE DIDN'T LOSE FAITH
WITH A MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS
PASSED THE PROPOSITION INSTEAD
HE SAW AN OPPORTUNITY AND
ORGANIZE A WELLSPRING OF NEW
LATINO VOTERS THROUGHOUT THE
SOUTH LAND. AND THEN FOR PARKS
MIKE. THIS IN EDUCATION
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATED FOR
THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES HE RETIRED FROM
THAT WORK IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUT
IS A LIFE OF ACTIVISM WOULD NOT
AND THERE WHEN PUBLISHED VOTE
BEGAN SLEEPING ON THE GROUNDS OF
CHURCH IN FULLERTON HE ORGANIZED
THE TRI PARISH HOMELESSNESS
COLLABORATIVE. A COLLABORATIVE
PUSH FOR THE CITY TO DECLARE A
HOMELESS- EMERGENCY TO OPEN
ACCESS TO FUNDING. ACTIVISTS
ALSO SOUGHT A SAFE OVERNIGHT
PARKING PILOT PROGRAM AT A
DESIGNATED CITY LOT. LASTLY THEY
ADVOCATED FOR THE FULLER TO
NAVIGATION AND RECOUP IF FIRST.
YOU'RE THE BAD HOMELESS SHELTER
HE LIVED TO SEE THE COLLAB SIX
ON THREE FROM. MICHAEL LIFTED IN
A LIFE IN THE SERVICE OF BOTH
GOD IN PEOPLE WHO NEEDED HELP IS
A LOT LONG COMMITMENT TO
COMMUNITY SERVICE AND ADVOCACY.
WILL FOREVER HAVE AN IMPACT ON
ORANGE COUNTY MIKE IS SURVIVED
BY HIS WIFE DINA FORK CHILDREN
SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN AND ONE
GREAT GRANDCHILD PLEASE JOIN
JOIN ENSURING CONDOLENCES WITH
THE CLEMENS FAMILY. THANK YOU
MISS CLARK SILVA THANK YOU
MEMBERS. PLEASE BRING THE NAME
SUGGESTS WE PRINT IN THE JOURNAL
ALL REQUEST RETURNING MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALL THE ROUNDS BIRTHDAY IS
TOMORROW. WHEN YOU SEE HIM AS
CALDERON PLEASE WISH HER A HAPPY
BIRTHDAY. SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS TUESDAY JANUARY TWENTY
FIFTH CHECK IN SESSION WEDNESDAY
JUNE TWENTY SIX. CHECK IN
SESSION THURSDAY JANUARY TWENTY
SEVENTH OF FOUR SESSIONS AT NINE
AM ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING
WILL BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED. FOR THE
BUSINESS. IT'S WHERE ABOUT. THEN
MOVES. AND WORKS SEX. THAT THIS
STANDS ADJOURNED THURSDAY
JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTH AT NINE
AM WE ARE ADJOURNED